we begin in Finland we're prime minister
Sana Marin has conceded defeat in the
Parliamentary election the right-wing
opposition National Coalition party won
worth 20.7 percent of the vote leader
pateri Oppo says he will work to form a
coalition government the Finns are
right-wing populist party came second
with 20.1 percent while the governing
social Democrats won 19.9 percent Rory
challenge reports
smiling and seemingly at ease for the
Selfies but Santa Marin's political star
has fallen finland's prime minister
gathered with supporters at her election
headquarters as ballot results came in
and showed her social Democrats slipping
behind the right-wing National Coalition
party and the Finn's party shortly after
she conceded defeat the Santa Marina is
coming to an end
NCP leader pateriopo is on track to be
the one assembling a new coalition
government
I'm very happy because these results it
is it's very strong and we have we have
a very good campaign and I think that in
election day today we have got more
boats and I'm quite sure that we can
keep our lead new prime minister
let's see about hope so thank you the
National Coalition party and the
nationalists of ricapura's fins party
have both benefited from worries about
the economy living costs are surging and
Finland is teetering into a recession
with her Youth and Progressive politics
Santa Marin has been popular among young
moderates at home and abroad Marin has
presided over finland's biggest
geopolitical transition in decades
applying to join nato in response to
neighboring Russia's invasion of Ukraine
last year opponents were quick to jump
on a leaked video of her drinking and
partying with friends saying she wasn't
fit to govern Marin was cleared of
wrongdoing but arguably criticism of her
government's public spending hit her
more than the Hedonism Scandal did for
me I'm burdened by the economics
actually we take too much debt I think I
wish we would have a welfare stay still
in 20 years time but with the current
expenditures and debt taking I'm worried
about how we can afford the welfare
state in the future I know Santa Maria
is very popular and
also think that she did an amazing job
with the coronavirus but maybe we have
to look at new
crises that we have and some of us still
believe that she does very good job but
other people need want something new
having become the world's youngest prime
minister at 34 Santa Marin will be an
ex-prime minister at 37. Rory challenge
Al Jazeera
well Christina Coco is the party
secretary for finland's National
Coalition party she joins us from
Helsinki thank you very much for being
on Al Jazeera first of all
congratulations on you when you now get
to form a coalition so which way are you
going to go with the fins on the far
right or with the social Democrats
well that's the one thing that we see
when the coming weeks are coming so uh
it's it's been an amazing election night
we we just won and uh we won uh 10 more
seats so it was a great night and now
now we are uh next thing is to focus to
get uh government uh ready so so it's
gonna be a very exciting week ahead any
indication at this point in time on
which way you think the party will go
our prime minister candidate better orpo
will uh will lead the negotiations and
it's going to be a tight negotiation in
in any cases so that's something that uh
we don't know yet okay as we heard in in
the story just earlier the economy was
one of the driving issues of the
selection how is the NCP going to tackle
you know a potential looming recession
and and the rising cost of living
yeah
uh Finnish people were very concerned
about State depth and all the economical
issues and now it's our
short try to balance
the public economy and also be sure that
people can have a world living so we
need of course a pro uh growth as well
as some maybe some cuts
okay well what does your win mean for
Ukraine and and finland's NATO bid
well NATO membership
thing to Finland of course and we are
looking It Forward very very uh glad but
um of course the situation in Ukraine is
still horrible and and we are trying to
give every support to Ukraine that we
can okay so there shouldn't be any
difference from the previous
administration to to your government in
in terms of support to Ukraine
no not not at all that's that's
something that we all uh share here in
Finland all the political parties are
very favor of supporting Ukraine with
such a close race uh between the three
major parties you know less than one
percent difference between all three how
difficult uh do you think it's going to
be to unite the country and what sort of
mandate does it give you a party
well uh we got quite strong mandate but
of course uh there's uh there were a
very tight race and and uh the parties
are quite close each other so of course
that's something that we we should take
uh uh take oh we should thought very
carefully out but I don't think that
that's that's got to be any any kind of
a problem because in Finland we are very
used to have a lot of different kind of
parties in in the same government so
it's it's quite common here okay it just
finally uh on sound American how do you
think that she will be remembered as a
leader
uh well uh there there was uh some uh
horrific times kovid and uh war in
Ukraine uh probably she will be
remembered for those okay thank you so
much uh for joining us on Al Jazeera
that is Christina Coco the party
secretary for finland's National
Coalition party thank you
thank you for having me